you can't wait for inspiration
you have to go after it with a club
life is not always a matter of holding
good cards
but sometimes playing a poor hand well
to be able to forget
means sanity
intelligent men are cruel
stupid men are monstrously cruel
the more you drink
the more you want
hate of some people binds them together
as love could never bind
it is far easier to see brave men die
than to hear a coward beg for life
you should rather be a superb meteor
every atom of yours in magnificent glow
then a sleepy and permanent planet
fear urges some people to go back
but growth drives them on
law is one thing
and right is another thing
ask any lawyer
some people are not half living
or quarter living
they were simply so many bags of bones
in which sparks of life flooded faintly
a bone to the dog is not charity
charity is the bone shared with the dog
when you are just as hungry as the dog
you should rather
be ashes than dust
the proper function of man is to live
not to exist
you should not waste your days in trying
to prolong them
you should use your time
the most beautiful stories always start
with wreckage
limited minds
can recognize limitations only in others
it's better to stand by someone's side
than by yourself
some people are not immoral
but merely unmoral
after all
only one life is given to a person
why not live it properly
and at the instant you knew
you ceased to know
affluence means influence
you may be beaten
but you are not broken
the trouble with some people is that
they have no imagination
a woman is a failed man
a person should not see himself in his
true form
then life becomes unbearable
no man can be intellectually insulted
insult in its very nature
is emotional
if cash comes with fame
come fame
if cash comes without fame
come cash
got to take a gamble
the only way to find out
is to find out
if a person is jealous
it means they loved
the human soul
is a lonely thing
it is not in what you succeed in doing
that you get your joy
but in the doing of it
man always gets less than he demands
from life
and so little do they demand
that the less than little they get
cannot save them
only life makes you suffer
it doesn't hurt to die
to die is to sleep
death is the end
peace
why then
do we all not want to die
many overworked intellectuals and
unskilled laborers succumbing to
delusion
take the path along which alcohol leads
them to death
when a man and a woman wish to unite
their hearts heads may roll and even
kingdoms fall
but they will not give up
nature
is a spendthrift
look at the fish and their millions of
eggs
for that matter
look at you and me
and our loins are the possibilities of
millions of lives
man rarely places a proper valuation
upon his woman kind
at least not until deprived of them
beauty will remain in the universe when
a person dies
but not vice versa
beauty does not depend on an
insignificant person wallowing in mud
beauty is the only master to serve
a good joke will sell faster than a good
poem
and measured by sweat and blood in
comparison with a poem
will bring the best reward
the fortunate man is the one who cannot
take more than a couple of drinks
without becoming intoxicated
avoid friends who drink
because they may drink to make you more
interesting to them
you make yourself weak when you say
you don't know how to do it
the purpose of life is prey
the essence of life is prey
life feeds on life
all living things in the world are
divided into those who eat
and those who are eaten
and this law said
eat
or they will eat you yourself
life is so short
you should sing one song rather than
interpret a thousand
show me a man with a tattoo
and i'll show you a man with an
interesting past
for life achieves its summit
when it does to the utmost that which it
was equipped to do
only reality never lies
to man
alone among the animals has been given
the awful privilege of reason
man with his brain
can penetrate the intoxicating show of
things and look upon the universe
brazenly
with indifference toward him and his
dreams
growth is life
and life is forever destined to make for
light
life that did not yearn toward life
was in fair way
towards ceasing
alcoholism is a product of barbarism
it has been holding humanity in a
stranglehold since the time of horry
and wild antiquity
and collects a monstrous tribute from it
devouring youth
undermining strength suppressing energy
destroying the best color of the human
race
life is always happy when it is
expressing itself
get a notebook
travel with it eat with it
throw into it every thought that
inadvertently appears in your head
cheap paper is still stronger than the
gray matter of the brain
and pencil notes store thoughts better
than memory
as one grows weaker one is less
susceptible to suffering there is less
hurt because there is less to hurt
to invent mortal sin
a man was needed with his imagination
and his power over matter
merely because you have got something to
say that may be of interest to others
does not free you from making all due
effort to express that something
in the best possible medium and form
there is a greater strength than wealth
and it is greater because it cannot be
taken away
our strength the strength of the
proletariat
is in our muscles
in our hands to cast ballots
in our fingers to pull triggers
you